they're not drones our small unmanned
aerial systems the technology will
evolve very quickly they contract you
the days or weeks become big brother
drones or flying robots are a type of
unmanned aircraft used by the military
for surveillance and warfare but now law
enforcement wants to use a version of
them as well sparking an age-old debate
across America how do you balance
technology with that creepy feeling the
big brother is watching you Alameda
County in Northern California tried to
answer that question at a recent public
meeting today we'd like to put on a
demonstration at a Power Point in
regards to small unmanned aerial systems
this is the sheriff of Alameda County
Gregory Ahern and he's proposing the use
of a small drone about the size of a
laptop to the county's public protection
committee so I think this is a future of
technology and I think if we do this
correctly I think we'll have a great
advantage over the other parts of our
nation and we can work together to make
sure this works correctly I think local
police departments want to get their
hands on drones right now because they
see it as an easy efficient way to
monitor what's going on in the city
Laurie Levenson is a professor of
criminal law at Loyola Law School in Los
Angeles that can be for the good make
sure people are saved but it can also be
creepy as it invades people's privacy so
that's the hot issue and that was the
chief concern among Alameda residents at
the public protection meeting people are
concerned about is that law-abiding
citizens will be surveilled the best
thing that a drone would be suited to do
is to surveil this roan is just another
mechanism to invade people's privacy and
spy on them or don't use these types of
devices for surveillance it's mission
specific to search areas for lost
children or elderly or Al's language
patients the search an area that be very
difficult or personnel diety you're
having the police department saying look
we're going to use it for good causes
we're going to use it for safety and
rescue but the people are saying how can
you trust but that's what's going to
happen
you might be using that to spy on for
example groups that are protesting
because they've had their fair number of
protesters or just using it against
certain communities what such rows in
your backyard you can see all sorts of
things maybe they're not illegal so
little embarrassing or maybe they're
just none of the government's business
prior to this meeting sheriff Ahern met
with civil liberties advocates to hear
recommendations for alleviating these
concerns um everyone has been so
professional and meeting with us
repeatedly we would also be more
delighted if they had taken more of our
recommendations one of those people he
met with was Linda Lai a lawyer with the
American Civil Liberties Union of
Northern California who came to the
meeting to speak the policy has proposed
invites the very kind of surveillance
that the sheriff agrees in principle
should not occur why says sheriff a
Hearns written privacy policy needs to
be more specific about what the
department can and cannot do right now
it's just too broad if the sheriff wants
a drone for search and rescue then the
policy should say that he can only use
it for search and rescue unfortunately
under his policy he can deploy a drone
for search and rescue but then use the
data for untold other purposes that is a
huge loophole it's an exception that
swallows the rule I just have to
disagree we're very protective of the
Fourth Amendment rights privacy rights
that is our job that's what we have to
continue to gain the public's trust so
we'd never breach that subject we urge
you today not to approve acquisition of
this device until written meaningful
safeguards are in place we have to
follow the law and we do follow the law
and that's our practice well I don't
think the local police departments now
know what to respect they haven't been
given frankly enough guy
if you're going to say we're going to
use it for a manhunt what do you call a
manhunt if you say you want to use it to
find missing persons well how far can
you go with that does that mean all of a
sudden you can use drugs inside of
people's apartment complex because the
person might be there it's a matter of
drawing lines but those long to report
trevor tim is an activist at the
Electronic Frontier Foundation and he
says drawing those lines with law
enforcement can be very hard police
always seem to want to push the
boundaries as far as the law will take
them and sometimes over those boundaries
so we have to stay vigilant against that
type of behavior right now it's hard to
tell exactly how many police departments
have this technology but the FAA itself
actually estimates that as many as
10,000 the drones may be flying over US
skies by the end of the decade the goal
is to get privacy laws in place
beforehand before they they reach that
level because once there are thousands
of drones in the sky the police can use
them for whatever they want it's going
to be very hard for citizens to get
their lawmakers to pass privacy laws
because you know once the police have a
certain power they never want to
relinquish it the more available this
type of technology is whether it's
because it's just easier to find it's
cheaper the like the more likely it'll
be abused because the more likely to be
used and if you have it readily
available why would you pause and say
you know what we want to do law
enforcement the old-fashioned way we
want to use warrants we want to send out
police officers it's just too easy to
become Big Brother Tim says that ease is
ushered in a new world a big data
collection by police and if you want an
example take your smartphone right now
it is a pervasive problem where police
are getting this type of information
where they can track you your exact
movements for days or weeks without a
warrant the New York Times reported just
last year that police agencies all over
the country have gotten this type of
data
1.3 million times you see because there
weren't strict privacy rules in place
with mobile phones first exploded onto
the market it made it that much easier
for law enforcement to obtain some
in data once the technology got more
advanced and if it can happen with
phones it can happen with drones this
policy allows the cross purposing of
data so that data collected for
search-and-rescue can be used for
criminal law enforcement that is a very
large exception that needs to be closed
generally there is this real friction
between technology and civil liberties
and we haven't really figured out how to
deal with it and frankly neither has a
Supreme Court because we are developing
much faster technologies that can allow
law enforcement and the government to
invade our privacy just look around you
on the street corner you have cameras in
the lights you have now these drones
that can go all around everywhere you go
the government can surveil you and yet
the law is written to deal with this go
back to the time of you know the framers
of the constitution what do they know
about drones the Supreme Court is trying
to deal with the issue of how do you
balance our Fourth Amendment interests
our privacy interests against what
technology can do we're wading out into
uncharted waters here we need to begin
to privacy safeguards into this template
one of those safeguards might just be
more technology you know it's not that
hard because of technology today to get
a warrant and so certainly law
enforcement could use that and any other
surveillance technique if an objective
impartial person like a judge says your
needs outweigh the privacy interests
what the real fight is right now is
letting the police unilaterally make
that decision what I think would be a
problem is if we say there are some
times we might need to use drones to
trust us we'll just use a woman
guy actually trust share favorite a lot
and I think he's one of the best
sheriffs in the United States okay so I
I feel that way
okay whatever privacy framework we adopt
now will be used as the baseline into
the future not only for Alameda but for
other jurisdictions across the country
we hope that Alameda becomes a leader in
privacy protections not privacy
violations I think their goals are noble
I don't think they're out there to
violate all our rights but if we don't
pay attention that's exactly what can
happen Alameda couldn't decide that day
if they would use drones or not the
debate is still going on there but when
it comes to technology and civil
liberties the debate may never be
settled for recent TV I'm Paul Detrick